first though we can speak to the health
secretary matt
hancock let's go straight to him thank
you very much for being on the program
i'm so far 2021 feels even worse
than 2020. we've got record numbers of
cases
daily deaths going over a thousand chris
witte this morning saying that in some
parts of the country
the nhs is facing the most dangerous
situation anyone can remember
is he right well it is a very
very serious situation in the nhs
especially
in some parts of the country but
actually
we've got challenges throughout the
whole of the uk
and the nhs needs you now more than it's
needed
anyone at any point and what it needs
people to do
is to stay at home as you say it's been
a difficult start to
2021 it always was going to be this is
the time of year when
when viruses find it easiest to spread
and we've got this new variant
which is so much more contagious
than the one we were dealing with for
most of last year
and so it is a very very serious
situation
hence the national lockdown but
critically people need to follow it and
stay at home
this is the point though isn't it you
know we're already in a national
lockdown
the schools are closed to all but key
workers and the most vulnerable we've
been told to stay at home
we've been told to work from home not
see our friends and family
do you actually have any other levers to
pull well the single biggest thing that
anybody can do
is to follow the stay at home guidance
there are
there are limited exemptions only if you
can't work from home
and if you need to go out and get
shopping or
take some exercise but these are
highly limited for a good reason and
that's because the pressure on the nhs
is
is very very bad and we need to
bring the case rate right down so it's
on all of us really it always has been a
big
team effort you know we in government
have
set rules and tried to set the the
framework of what can get the virus
under control and then keep it under
control but it's on all of us
to follow those rules and to stay at
home wherever possible
so i mean it sounds listening to you
that some people aren't following the
rules what exactly does your compliance
data show
what are people doing wrong well the
vast majority of people are following
the rules
the data shows that more people are
following the rules than during the
november lockdown
and that's very important because it's
less people than the first
lockdown well it's harder to measure
because um
we didn't we didn't have the uh the the
data
surveillance in the same way that we do
now uh back in march because we built
those systems up over the summer to be
able to
to follow this more closely but as far
as you can tell less people obeying the
rules now than they did
in that first lockdown as far as we can
tell the vast majority of people are
obeying the
rules but it's very very important that
everybody does
because this via this new variant it can
pass from one person to the other so
so easily so you need to stay out of
contact with other people
outside of your household wherever
possible and
that is the way that we can bring this
down and and
you know the faster we can bring it down
the more we can relieve the pressure on
the nhs but the first thing we've got to
do collectively
is stop it from going up because that's
what's happening at the moment
it sounds like you know you don't want
to directly criticize the public
but are people not following the rules
obviously i accept that the
majority of people are but what does the
data show are there some people who are
not following the rules and what are
they doing wrong
well we are going we are as you can see
with the police
enforcing stringently against the
minority who
don't follow the rules um but you're
right i don't want to criticize the
public
because the majority of people are
following the rules
that's what we can see and we can see
that the amount of people who are
who are staying at home has increased
but we've just got to all
absolutely follow that and keep
following it you know you said at the
top of the interview you said um
yeah this has been a really difficult
start to 2021 and it has
and we always knew these winter
months were going to be the most
difficult even with that
that hope on the horizon it's not just
on the horizon it's here it's in
it's in gp surgeries right across the
land
with the rollout of the vaccine but just
because the vaccine's coming
we can't let up because the pressure on
the nhs
is right here right now and
and the nhs needs everybody to stop
passing on this virus and the way to do
that is to stay at home
um i want to talk about the vaccine roll
up but just one more question on
compliance when we saw two women find
200 pounds for
driving a short distance to a beauty
stop and
bought in derbyshire to have a walk with
the police right to find them and could
we see more fines like this in the
future
well i think the police have been doing
an absolutely brilliant job very
difficult circumstances
but specifically on that case well i
absolutely am going to
back the police because the challenge
here is that
every flex can be fatal you know you
might look at the rules and think well
it doesn't matter too much if i just do
this or do that
but the these rules are not there as
a as as boundaries to be pushed they're
the limit of what people should be doing
and everybody everything i just want to
just clarify if you drive somewhere
for a walk you can expect to be fined by
the police well obviously i don't know
the
specific circumstances and i i support
the police in doing
their very difficult job which they're
doing very sensitively
but they're also right to take
very seriously the rules we've brought
in you know we haven't brought them in
because we
wanted to we've brought them in because
we've had to um
and every flexibility could be fatal
because if you just say i'll just flex
this bit of the rules the problem is
this virus is so contagious it then
passes on
and then as we've seen it is deadly and
there are
there are there are people dying every
day and the nhs has got this enormous
pressure on it like it's never seen
before
okay you're ramping up testing in people
without symptoms particularly
uh key workers if you haven't got
symptoms but you want to test when can
you
expect to be able to get one well we're
increasing this all the time and we're
announcing today that we're taking it
from
the existing around a third of the
country where this service is available
to be available across the whole of
england and the similar schemes
available in
scotland wales and northern ireland um
and so we'll expand this over this month
to cover all parts and we're
doing it not just uh geographically
working with local councils but also
through
employers uh for instance uh in
in government there are some people who
do have to go into the office
and making sure that they have a testing
regime in the same way that we've
already got one in the nhs
uh and in in care homes so
this is about trying to make sure the
people who do have to
leave home to go to work can stay
safe and we can find those find those
positive cases
and uh help people to self-isolate and
obviously
give them treatment if that's what's
needed so it's an important
tool in the armory it isn't the only
tool in the armory but it is a it's an
important one that's being rolled out
um so we talked about testing we talked
about compliance but of course
you know the real way out of this is
through vaccination
um the prime minister has said he wants
to vaccinate 13 million people by
mid-february to do that we'd need to be
vaccinating about 2 million people
a week so how many people have now been
vaccinated and are we on course to hit
that target of 2 million a week
yes we're on course the rate limiting
factor at the moment is supply but
that's increasing
i'm very glad to say that at the moment
we're running at over
200 000 people being vaccinated every
day
and amongst the over 80s who of course
are
absolutely crucial because the you know
it's older people who tend to
be most affected by this virus we've now
vaccinated around a third of the over
80s
in this country so we're making
significant progress
but there's still further expansion to
go this week we're opening mass
vaccination centers
so alongside the gp centers which got
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine for the
first time
last week this week we're opening
mass vaccination centers big sites for
instance at epsom race course
and uh there's seven going live this
week and then there'll be more to come
the next week
where we'll get through very large
numbers of people
so if we do manage to get to that target
of vaccinating 13 million people by
mid-february the most vulnerable
people working in our care homes at nhs
could we start lifting restrictions then
well of course after you've been
vaccinated it still takes two to three
weeks to get
the um to get protection and
then obviously we'll be watching the
data very carefully the good news is
that with the vaccine the link
from the number of cases through to the
number of people who
die from covid that link should be
broken
we've already managed to bear down on
that uh
that inevitable path from the number of
cases through to the number of people in
hospital
so we've given that given the fact that
we that more people are vaccinated that
the more we will be able to bear down on
the virus when do you expect to see
restrictions lifted mid-february
mid-april
when are we hoping well we've always
said in the spring
and we'll hold to that and the reason is
that
we we will have vaccinated the
most vulnerable groups the over 70s the
clinically extremely vulnerable
um by the by the middle of february
it then takes two to three weeks for the
immunity to
come through from the first dose and
we'll watch the data
well we'll watch the data that's the
reason that we don't put a specific date
on it
is because we don't yet know we still
don't know
the effect of the vaccine on
transmission
when you say spring though what do you
mean by spring when does spring end
i know it sounds stupid but it's quite
an important question
well obviously we'll bring these we'll
bring the restrictions to it end as soon
as we possibly and safely can
they formally end on the 31st of march
the current restrictions in law
but we hope to make progress before then
and
um there's a but it but it we will we'll
follow the data because it's about
keeping people safe and
soon in a matter of a few weeks we'll be
able to see the impact
of vaccination on how much that reduces
cases amongst the over 80s how much it
reduces deaths
i'm optimistic about that because we
know from the trials that the vaccines
uh reduce the number of people who are
hospitalized very very significantly
and um and and we've now you know as i
say we've vaccinated around a third of
the
over 80s so within a few weeks that's a
third
of the the most vulnerable people who
will be
protected from hospitalization from this
disease and
a large the large majority of them
protected from getting it at all
so we've got watching that will be
absolutely critical to being able to
answer the question which
of course i know that not only you but
everybody watching wants to know which
is when are we going to be able to lift
the restrictions and that's what the
acceleration of the vaccine rollout
program is
all about yeah the all-important
question certainly and chris
witte england's chief medical officer
has said that we may have to reintroduce
some restrictions next winter do you
think that is a possibility
well i really hope not i mean i hope
that
uh we will be able to handle this in the
future
through a vaccination program uh
in the same way that we do flu each year
um
we have annual vaccines then do you
think like flu i i think it's highly
likely that there'll be a dual
vaccination program
uh you know for the foreseeable and this
is in the medium
the medium term um of flu and
covid you know flu vaccination rates are
at their highest level ever
we've over 80 percent of the over 65
year olds have
been vaccinated for flu this year that's
the biggest increases big jump on last
year when it was around 70
that's that's very good news it's good
news for two reasons firstly
to protect people against flu secondly
because it shows the vast vast majority
of over 65s
are up for getting vaccinated which is
brilliant and
important um so for the foreseeable
future i
i expect that we'll have a dual flu and
covert vaccination program
not least because we've seen these new
variants so far there's no evidence that
any new variant
uh it gets around the vaccine
but we'll have to update the vaccines to
be targeted
if further new variants come through
okay um
just quickly before we move on yes or no
it's fine
have you spoken to tony blair about
vaccinations well i talk to all sorts of
people all the time
and uh what about tony blair say yes
well i talk
i'm not gonna go into private
conversations i talk to all sorts of
people and
we take uh ideas from from from lots of
sources
okay not a no um now school's really
important of course for so many
of our viewers and children and parents
schools are only
open to the vulnerable and
the children of key workers but of
course we know that it does feel as
though schools are a lot busier than
they were during the first lockdown
if you're a key worker and you could
educate your children from home should
you avoid sending them to school if
possible
yes it's always been the guidance that
schools are
there for key workers children where
key workers need to have the children in
school in order to be able to get
to work so say one of you is a key
worker then do you think that really you
should be keeping your child at home
if at all possible yes so for instance
if you're a key worker
and you're and your partner and doesn't
work
then you shouldn't be sending your
children to school that's clear in the
guidance
um but of course the reason that we keep
schools open
for key workers children is that this is
important you know it's important that
uh that key workers for instance in the
nhs but not just the nhs can get to work
and and so it's a very difficult balance
to strike
i understand that more people are
sending their children to school than
they did
uh last time we've also got but we we
really do need
everybody who works in the nhs where
it's all possible to be able to
make it to work because you know these
pressures are real and significant and
you know i just want to um thank all the
people who are going out to work in the
nhs
even under these pressure circumstances
i'm i'm constantly inspired by the
amazing work ethic of everybody in the
nhs they yeah some people
go above and beyond something we can
certainly all get behind um
on schools within the last week the
prime minister has said
that schools are safe and that schools
may act as vectors
a transmission of the virus how can both
of those statements be true
well both are true and they're not they
can't both be true can they i mean look
you can say that
schools are low risk that the benefits
of going to school outweigh the risks
of losing out on the education but i
just can't see how you can say that
schools
are safe but they also transmit the
virus how does that work
well then let me explain because the
prime minister i thought explained it
extremely well
both last sunday and last monday when
this was being discussed
schools are safe for children the risk
to children is extremely low
and there's no evidence of more teachers
catching covid than any other profession
so that means schools are safe but the
challenge is that because children often
catch it asymptomatically
i mean adults do too right a third of
adults
who get coveted don't have any symptoms
at all but still pass it on
with children that proportion is much
much higher and so
the the so schools can still uh
cause spread whilst being safe for the
children who are in them
so that's that's the precise explanation
for why the prime minister was right to
say schools are both
safe but they do contribute to the
spread which is why unfortunately we've
had to close them
you can see why you know some teachers
are holding their heads in their hands
you know on sunday they're told schools
are safe on monday they're ordered to
close
gavin williamson is one week threatening
councils with legal action if they close
schools then he's later doing it himself
the department for education promised to
give children laptops for remote
learning all the way back in april many
still haven't got them according to
reports you apparently asked a meeting
this week
what have they been doing for the last
six months i mean it's a pretty good
question what's the answer
no that report was wrong and the what
they're doing right now
is distributing the the laptops
and i think that's important i think
there's over i'm told
there's over half a million laptops that
have been uh distributed
now this is a really important and it's
important that it's happening
right now um and i i think you know the
dfe have been working
incredibly hard in very difficult
circumstances
and difficult circumstances brought on
by the need to control the virus
and they i think that it's been
it of course it's a challenge in
education
when the rules and the approach changes
because the data changes this is the
thing and
and the sophie the frank truth is the
public uh completely get this
when there's a new variant of a virus
that is
um that is spreading fast then we have
to act
fast to control it i think the public
really understand that and then
and i know that the public would rather
that we acted uh
rather than uh thinking saying well
you know somebody in the media is going
to call it a u-turn that isn't
that is what matters what matters is
taking the right decisions
based on the latest data that you have
public think
um gavin williamson said that you know
parents with concerns about their school
should contact ofsted who should parents
contact
if they've got concerns about the
performance of gavin williamson
well i think gavin's been doing a
brilliant job in very difficult
circumstances
and it actually it's incumbent on all of
us
frankly the whole country to pull
together as much as possible
you know this is something that we can't
get through uh
by uh by by only some people acting
everybody has a role to play and yes of
course
yes of course we in government have a a
a critical
responsibility and i you know i feel
that
uh the the duty to get these decisions
right
i feel that very heavily but we've all
got it we've all got a responsibility
and i frankly i don't think um
politics comes into it what matters is
making the right substantive judgments
and trying to make those judgments on
the best latest available information so
if if politics doesn't come into it um
what do you think persuaded the prime
minister to appoint the
former chief whip who knows where all
the bodies are buried to the job of
education secretary
well i think gavin's been doing a great
job and i i think what matters is
people working you know working at all
of us working as a team
and but it's not just about government
that's the thing right we talk to
a huge range of people outside
government as well but it also comes
down to every single one of your viewers
this is a huge team effort and that's
that's how
it's the only way that we can get
through this best uh is if people
pull together in these very difficult
circumstances
and everybody takes their responsibility
and for most people that responsibility
is to stay at home and to minimize
all social contact where it is possibly
avoidable
because that's how the country will best
get through this we are out of time but
just one question very quickly
um twitter has suspended donald trump's
account after his supporters
some of his supporters i should say
stormed the capital was
twitter right to do that well
i think it raises a very important
question which is it it means that the
social media platforms are taking
editorial decisions
and that is a very big question
uh because then it raises questions
about uh
about their editorial judgments and the
and the way that they're regulated
uh it's obviously a one for the culture
secretary but as a former culture
secretary i can tell you i think that
i i think it does lead to very
interesting questions about the role of
social media
and the role of the social media
companies and the decision the editorial
decisions that they take
okay um thank you very much for coming
on the program always good to talk matt
hancock there